uh what let's see why don't we go next
to um
there's just so many interesting people
let's just try let's just try
tom from green bay once more tom are you
are you able to unmute yourself in chat
now
wow that's really too bad
really too bad
let's try oz from kentucky oz from
kentucky you're on the air this isn't dr
oz is it
no no he's stealing my uh he's robbing
my name how's it going dave can you hear
me i can hear you fine oz
great it's been so long since i got to
talk to you know it was a
pre pandemic last time i spoke to you so
is that true it's been that long
i'm a little nervous right now because i
wasn't expecting to
be on the air here um you're doing great
what what's on your mind os
well a lot of things so since the last
time i talked you know the pandemic and
everything's it's horrible for everybody
and particularly it was hard for me i
lost my grandma i'm sorry to hear that
it was a nursing home casualty here in
kentucky and
so it was a hard time especially for
people like me who are alcoholics and i
wasn't a binge for quite a while but i'm
sober again um that's fantastic how how
long have you been sober
well it's been about a month and a half
that's that's great us i'm so glad to
hear that
thank you and um yeah i've got mental
health treatment that i've needed too
that you know
i was homeless for years yeah and uh
i used to live in california and i moved
back to kentucky because i got tired
tired of dealing with the wildfires
there
i used to
work on them as because i'm a i work in
forestry
i used to i'm a community organizer now
but um okay
so much stuff like you know i haven't
talked to you the george all the racial
justice pro and police brutality
protests you know i got shot during a
protest in cincinnati you you were shot
at or you actually got shot
that was rubber bullets pretty much
almost uh i'm probably like 10 feet away
on purpose i had my hands up and they
shot they were trying to shoot me in the
crotch they shot me in the leg so a
rubber bullet hit your leg what how how
injured were you
i turned my thigh black and blue i've
got pictures of it but uh oh my gosh did
you need i mean does that require
treatment
i didn't i didn't get any treatment for
it healed okay but wow and pepper
sprayed i mean pepper balled and stuff
too got hit with those but um
really all this stuff i haven't talked i
mean
the whole thing
as soon as trump got elected i knew i
was mortified because i i've
lived around those people you know like
skinheads and nazis i've been in prison
before i know how they think
unfortunately and
when he was elected
i just saw like these people these are
neo-confederates they're they're clan
they're the
nazis they're and they want to overthrow
the government they won a civil war i
knew it back then so
i was this whole during his whole
presidency i was just
constant meltdown
and then when the january 6th happened i
was just
you know
it was i mean i have
ptsd and all kinds of stuff so seeing
that i was in the military too i wasn't
in combat but i was in the marines and
so just seeing all that stuff happen
just was so traumatic yeah like it was
it just made it so much harder to get
sober i finally did and um i lost you
know a lot of family would were lost to
queueing on
like almost my entire family just
because some of them have kind of come
out of it but like my dad he's a truck
driver so he listens to like oan all day
and on in his truck dear god
well listen
i can't tell you how glad i am to hear
that you're six weeks sober i'm glad
that uh you know the rubber bullet
you you seem to be doing all right
and uh i hope that you know we've got
we've got better times ahead i'm gonna
let you go because we have so many
people waiting to chime in but it's
great to hear from you oz